bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat place cet après midi à
la suite des travaux de la commission d'
enquête sur les autorités
administratives indépendantes
une commission d' enquête qui a été
créée à l'initiative du groupe rdse il
ya quelques mois déjà et qui a
d'ailleurs pour rapporteur le sénateur
rds jacques mézard président donc du
groupe rdse
cette commission denquête a été créé
afin de voir si les autorités
administratives indépendantes qui ont
aujourd'hui un rôle central dans nos
institutions n'ont justement pas pris
trop de pouvoir cela a notamment au
détriment des pouvoirs exécutifs ou
encore législatif place cet après midi à
l'audition du médiateur du cinéma
le médiateur du cinéma c'est une toute
petite institution puisque la médiatrice
du cinéma elle même n'occupe pas cette
fonction à temps complet son objectif
est bien arrivé à régler les litiges
entre les exploitants et les
distributeurs dans le monde du cinéma
cela grâce à la conciliation je vous
donne un exemple lors du succès
historique d'intouchable da il y avait
eu de très nombreuses salles de cinéma
qui avait décidé de reprogrammer ce film
sur plusieurs semaines mais le problème
est bien c'est que du coup et bien
d'autres films n'avaient pas pu être
programmés dans ce contexte est bien le
médiateur du cinéma avaient dû
intervenir tout de suite donc retour à
cette audition qui est également
l'occasion de découvrir l'économie
globale du cinéma nous sommes une
autorité indépendante d'un genre très
particulier à divers titres
d'abord parce que nous nous opérons dans
le domaine de la médiation de la
conciliation donc c'est déjà un domaine
particulier parce qu'il s'agit du
domaine du cinéma
qui est vous le savez bien un domaine où
il ya une politique publique très active
donc c'est un domaine réguler
et aussi parce que nous intervenons
dans les litiges entre exploitants de
salles et distributeurs de films c'est à
dire dans un milieu de la distribution
qui est aussi très particulier puisqu'il
s'agit d'une distribution sélective
donc
voilà à peu près déjà ce qui nous
caractérise
évidemment vous avez bien noté que nous
sommes une toute petite structure
c'est à dire moi même à temps très
partiel
un cadreur attend à temps plein et un
un agent de catégorie c à à temps plein
donc évidemment nous n'avons pas
comment dire de personnalité juridique
et nous sommes rattachés au cnc en
matière en matière de moyens en matière
budgétaire donc nous sommes rattachés
nous sommes inscrits vous sur le budget
du cnc
donc voilà très globalement ce qui ce
qui nous caractérise
je peux si vous souhaitez vous expliquer
nos missions puisqu'elles ne sont pas
exclusivement centrée sur la médiation
comme vous l'avez peut-être noté un donc
le médiateur du cinéma à 3
3 axes dans ses missions le premier le
plus le plus évident c'est celui c'est
le rôle de médiation
donc là c'est vraiment concentré sur les
litiges comme je le disais entre
exploitants de salles de cinéma et
distributeurs de films
litiges qui peuvent être portées à la
connaissance du médiateur soit par l'une
des deux parties prenantes au litige
soit par d'autres intervenants les
fédérations le cnc ou le médiateur peut
aussi s'autosaisir
donc ça c'est un premier volet de nos de
nos activités il faut avoir en tête
quand même que qui a plusieurs milliers
de salles de cinéma enfin
d'établissement de cinéma en france et
ils ont une centaine de distributeurs et
que vu quand comment dire dans la
situation actuelle on a peut-être
pour donner un ordre de grandeur 400
films inédits qui sortent par an
ce qui fait que si vous voulez la denrée
rare sur ce marché là c'est la salle
c'est pas le film les films il en sort
beaucoup toutes les semaines est
en quelque sorte ils les distributeurs
se battent pour avoir les salles
bon c'est évidemment c'est pas toujours
comme ça que ça se passe mais c'est je
vous décris le schéma à grands traits
alors il faut aussi avoir conscience que
dans ce milieu là il ya une très grande
concentration
à la fois du côté des exploitants de
salles où vous avez toutes les formes de
d'exploitation mais vous avez un
relativement petit nombre d'opérateurs
qui concentre une grande partie des
entrées
et de l'autre côté côté des
distributeurs vous avez aussi des
distributeurs extrêmement puissant et
d'autres qui le sont beaucoup moins et
évidemment tout ça ce
se décline ensuite par typologie de
films puisque qu'il s'agisse des salles
ou des distributeurs ils peuvent tout à
fait être spécialisés dans un dans une
ligne éditoriale particulière elle en
particulier les cinémas qui sont classés
art et essai ont une typologie assez
différentes de
multiplexes qui sont implantés en
périphérie de zones urbaines par exemple
donc ça c'est la ligne éditoriale de
chaque de chaque établissement donc tout
ceci tout ceci voilà
fait apparaître un certain nombre de
litiges au moment du placement des films
sur différents sujets dont je peux vous
donner des exemples si vous souhaitez
être éclairé voilà alors ça quel est le
donc c'est une c'est une activité de
médiation tout à fait classique
le médiateur du cinéma a un pouvoir
d'injonction dont il use
avec modération puisque évidemment c'est
sous le contrôle du conseil d'état ce
type de décision
mais qui est une qui est une vraie
possibilité dans un certain nombre de
cas de sortir de sortir d'un litige qui
n'a pas eu d'issue à la fin de la de la
conciliation de la phase de conciliation
il faut avoir conscience que ces
médiations elles ont elles ont un rôle
immédiat de résolution des litiges elles
ont aussi un rôle dans un certain nombre
de cas de défrichage d'un domaine et il
est fréquent que nous ayons des
médiations sur des sur des sujets qui
animent le débat de la profession à un
moment donné
pour vous donner un exemple sur disons
2014 2015 ce qu'on a vu monter en
puissance c'est des sujets sur les
conditions d'exploitation c'est-à-dire
le nombre de semaines
d'exploitation le nombre de séances
consacrées au film et ce sont des sujets
de plus en plus comme on dit difficile à
gérer dans les salles compte tenu du
nombre de deux films qui sont qui sont
exposés
donc sur ce type de litige évidemment
nous nous intervenons sur un litige très
précis donc mais quelques fois nous
sommes appelés soit rappelé des règles
générales soi à soi à décrire des bonnes
pratiques soient a
esquissé des pistes qui ont une valeur
au delà du cas particulier qui est
traitée donc dans ce cas là nous rendons
publics
ces éléments là sous forme d'une
recommandation par exemple de manière à
ce que
les autres parties prenantes qui sont
aussi qu'ils ont aussi ce type de
difficulté puisse se saisir de ce qui
est dit à cette occasion la voilà donc
sur les conditions d'exploitation mais
aussi par exemple sur l'organisation des
avant-premières on a eu des sujets
nouveaux on n'avait pas tellement ce
genre de litige montanes a eu sur
l'organisation de festivals c'est avec
les festivals de cinéma se développe
extrêmement et que ça peut poser des
problèmes de concurrence
sur la diffusion des films de patrimoine
ou les conditions de diffusion des films
de patrimoine
peuvent parfois posé poser les questions
en termes de concurrence
bon voila voila une série de litiges
nouveau sur une période donnée quoi donc
voyez on accompagne aussi les débats de
la profession comme par exemple ça a pu
être le cas aussi l'an dernier avec avec
les sujets liés à la
ventes liées par exemple c'est à dire
aux ventes combinée d'un ticket de
cinéma avec une
boisson une confiserie des choses les
gens là bon donc et qui sont des débats
assez rude dents dans la profession
voilà un petit peu l'esprit delà du
volet médiation dans leur nous avons
deux autres volets d'activités
que la loi nous confie l'un porte sur
les créances une création extension de
multiplexes ou rénovation de multiplex
sur le territoire
où comme vous le savez ce sont des
commissions départementales
qui qui prennent ces décisions
qui peuvent être ensuite
les recours peuvent être formées devant
la commission nationale donc quel est le
rôle du médiateur là dessus il a la
possibilité de former des recours
quand il estime que l'intérêt général
n'est pas n'est pas respectée dans une
décision de commission départementale
voilà donc donc nous examinons toutes
les décisions des commissions
départementales et nous formons un
certain nombre de recours alors en gros
j'ai regardé les chiffres ce doit être
un petit 10 % des dossiers
décidé en commission départementale et
c'est un sujet qui est extrêmement actif
puisque vous le savez très très
vraisemblablement ses projets de
création d'extension sont nombreux que
le flux ne t'arrive pas
alors qu'on a quand même un pays
extrêmement bien l'équipe et quand on
regarde au niveau international on a
alors d'ailleurs il faut dire que c'est
aussi grâce à tous ces renouvellements
extension créations qu'on a un pays si
bien équipé mais il faut voir que ce
flux ne tarit pas au moins ou au niveau
des demandes et donc des autorisations
au niveau des réalisations
on a aussi j'ai pas l'an dernier par
exemple on devait avoir on a dû avoir 45
dossiers en commission départementale
39 autorisé de façon définitive et au
niveau des réalisations ces
autorisations qui ont été données dans
les années précédentes on en avait aussi
une petite quarantaine c'est assez
considérable quand même année après
année sur le territoire national c'est
pour vous donner une idée des tensions
qui peut y avoir mais vous les
connaissez sans doute puisque vous êtes
vous êtes proche de vos terrains
avec à la fois l'intérêt pour les villes
ou pour les communautés urbaines ou même
pour les petites communes de
de réfléchir à leur aménagement
cinématographique et et la difficulté de
le faire parce qu'il faut aussi que ce
soit que ce soit un domaine économique
qui fonctionne voilà donc il nous arrive
d'être en relation avec avec les élus
pour les aider en fait pour leur
expliquer un certain nombre de choses et
en particulier si vous voulez le sujet
depuis quelques années c'est
comment lors de la construction d'un
nouveau gros multiplex sur une zone
comment préserver
la dynamique des établissements qui sont
déjà implantés et qui assure la
diversité des formes d'exploitation sur
le sur le territoire si vous voulez avec
à la fois le débat
centre-ville versus périphérie mais
aussi le débat stahl art et essai versus
multiplex ou bien tout simplement
animations animation autour d'un cinéma
où zone commerciale
et animation d'une zone commerciale donc
il ya des outils pour faire ça qui se
sont un petit peu développé et que nous
essayons de rendre opérationnels
qui sont des engagements les engagements
de programmation que peut prendre le
créateur du multiplexe voilà
là dessus il ya beaucoup à dire et bon
j'ai eu l'occasion un certain nombre de
fois de de m'exprimer sur les limites de
cet outil et les précautions à prendre
et notamment par les élus pour éviter de
bah de tomber sous le coup
de la politique de la concurrence quoi
on peut pas on peut pas signer des
accords entre entre concurrents même si
la mairie signé avec
secteu ment pas de sens mais il ya quand
même des moyens d'agir dans ce domaine
là et donc c'est un peu ce qu'on essaie
de ce qu'on essaie de développer
troisième volet
troisième volet donc c'est les
engagements de programmation alors là
c'est bon la loi impose comme vous le
savez aux gros exploitants
disons qu'ils sont puissants soit au
niveau local soit au niveau national
de prendre des engagements de
programmation
pour servir l'intérêt général donc pour
servir la diversité diversité des
oeuvres proposées
et pour par exemple limiter la
multidiffusion si vous voulez me limiter
l'écrasement
d'un film blockbuster sur un nombre
d'écrans excessif oui pour laisser de la
place aux formes aux formes d'oeuvre
différentes bon donc sur sur ce genre de
sujet notre rôle c'est de donner un avis
sur les propositions qui sont faites par
ces exploitants donc nous donnons à vic
à la fois évidemment nous transmettons à
l'exploitant que nous rendons publics et
que nous
adressons en tout premier lieu au cnc
puisque que c'est le cnt qui est
décisionnaire sur ces sujets est donc
cet outil de régulation qui ce que sont
les engagements de programmation
qui est un outil
très qui est bien connu dans la
profession mais qui qui est peut-être
insuffisamment mobilisés
qui pourrait être renforcé
c'est un je pense que c'est un sujet qui
est d'importance pour l'avenir parce que
disons parmi les outils de régulation de
terrain dont on dispose il n'y en a pas
tant que ça et c'en est un
voilà bon je vous ai tracé à très grands
traits ce que nous faisons et nous
publions chaque année un
rapport un rapport annuel qui essaient
de faire un peu le point sur sur toutes
ces questions
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez la parole
leur honte
madame la présidente
ma première question est relative
à la qualité
d'autorité administrative indépendante
en ce qui concerne votre autorité elle
n'est pas reconnue par la loi en tant
que tel mais par l'étude le rapport du
conseil d'état de 2001
pour vous qu'est ce qui peut justifier
ce statut et on avait vos besoins
alors
aujourd'hui
le médiateur du cinéma prend ses
décisions en toute indépendance en toute
indépendance en particulier vis à vis du
gouvernement bien entendu mais aussi
vis-à-vis du cnc qui est si je puis dire
le bras armé de la politique du cinéma
en france
donc l'indépendance nous l'avons je veux
dire sur ce plan là totalement
est ce qu'on a besoin d'un statut
d'autorité indépendante pour cela
je joue
comment expliquer ça je pense que
il est important que notre autonomie
soit reconnu notre indépendance sont
reconnues
chaque fois que nos collègues change au
cnc il faut qu'on leur ait explique qu
est ce que ça veut dire l'autonomie
l'indépendance
parce que nous avons des rapports
fréquents avec eux parce que nous
dépendons du cnc pour nos moyens donc
par exemple quand nous avons besoin de
rhji un bond des choses très simple de
faire évoluer notre notre site internet
si vous avez la curiosité d'aller le
voir il est extrêmement vétustes
bon ben voilà c'est c'est une c pas une
priorité à l'intérieur du budget
informatique du cnc jeu je le comprends
très bien
quand comment dire quand quand nous
avons besoin d'études
et là je dirais on est plus proche du
coeur du métier nous avons une très
bonne écoute des équipes du cnc mais les
équipes du cnc ont aussi leur travail à
faire et je dois dire que
pour toutes les choses qui sont
réellement opérationnels comme comme les
études voire même le conseil juridique
quand il nous arrive d'avoir d'avoir
besoin d'un
conseil juridique
ça fonctionne bien les échanges que nous
avons avec les services chargés du
cinéma pour leur demander de
l'information autres sapho ça fonctionne
bien
par contre il arrive que nous soyons
obligés en particulier quand il ya un
changement de personne mais c'est tout à
fait normal de redire que
sur tel sujet et ils sont très aimables
de nous donner leurs analyses mais c'est
à nous instruire donc enfin voyez c'est
des choses extrêmement
subtil
mais l'indépendance passe par là
voilà alors nous faisons nous n'avons
aucun problème d'indépendance vis-à-vis
du cnc mais je pense que si rien ne
disait nulle part que nous avons degré
d'autonomie il ya fort à parier que que
le médiateur du cinéma serait absorbée
par la mécanique du cnc je le dis sans
aucune animosité encore une fois nous
avons d'excellentes relations avec le
cnc et nous travaillons en très bonne
intelligence mais on est déjà rattaché
pour tout ce qui est moyen pour tout ce
qui est budgétaire
pour tout ce qui est
vraiment de la vie quotidienne les
arbitrages à prendre sur l'émission
chose comme ça c'est extrêmement bon et
tout ça se passe bien mais de temps en
temps ça mais quand même très utile de
pouvoir rappeler que nous sommes une
autorité indépendante
voilà alors ceci dit c'est absolument
pas consommateur de crédits publics le
notre degré de
d'indépendance non si vous voulez je
crois qu'il faut aussi regarder les
choses sous cet angle là nous sommes une
toute petite équipe et nous
fonctionnement nous fonctionnons sans
aucun
je dirai évidemment si on avait créé une
agence indépendante ça aurait été
complètement ridicule puisque il aurait
fallu qu'on ait des gestionnaires bon
donc là tout ce qui est fonction support
est totalement mutualiser ce qui me
paraît bien ce qui me paraît nécessaire
mais en même temps
ça n'est pas inutile du tout que le que
l'indépendance soit reconnue alors sous
quelle forme peut-il le faire je pense
que c'était la façon la plus simple de
le faire
oui mais vous venez de nous dire que par
exemple si votre site internet est
vieillot
il est efficace quand même voix sur les
formations
mais s'il cnc ne vais pas
donner les moyens financiers pour le
moderniser et va vous rester comme ça
oui non c'est pas qu'il ne veut pas
c'est qu'on se trouve dans une mécanique
1 avec des priorités il ya eu des
refontes dont je bénéficie aussi bien
entendu des refonte du système
d'information si vous estimez que pour
vous c'est une priorité et que cela est
nécessaire pour un bon fonctionnement de
votre autorité vous êtes quand même
sous
le couperet d'une décision du cnc tout à
fait mais
une indépendance relative
oui mais en même temps bon je ne
je pense qu'il faut relativiser les
choses on est quand même dans une
période où les l'ensemble des
administrations publiques doivent faire
des économies et donc nous mêmes
supposions qu'elle en faisait toujours
que même soit la période même si nous
comptions sur la cour des comptes là
pour veiller à cela tout à fait mais
donc même si j'avais un budget il est
possible aussi que je décide que
finalement
j'ai pas les crédits 20 mai crédit
doivent être prioritairement affectés à
autre chose voyez je sais pas une
critique c'est juste pour vous donner
des exemples tangibles de ce que c'est
dans la vie quotidienne
et qu'elle est
quels problèmes cela poserait-il que vos
fonctions soient exercées par le cnc
ça en poserait parce que le cnc a des
roses a des relations très étroites avec
la profession sous différents aspects il
il attribue des subventions ou ou des
aides qu'il s'agisse du domaine de
l'exploitation ou du domaine de la
distribution et donc c'est difficile de
ce fait l'un d'eux se poser en
en autorité
comment dire non liés au parti parce que
c'est ça en fait le médiateur s'est
il faut qu'il est
il faut qu'il soit reconnu ben c'est
le pouvoir par exemple de contester une
décision
du cnc sur un financement accordé par le
sel c'est ça n'est pas dans mes
attributions du tout c'est à dire que je
ne m'occupe pas du tout de litige qui
pourrait exister entre
un demandeur dead auprès du cnc et le
cnc ça n'est pas du tout dans mes
attributions
dont je
parle on
a ce serait se serait imaginé que il
commencerait par saisir le ministre puis
ensuite je puis ensuite les tribunaux
administratifs si vraiment il y avait un
abus
parce que quand même vos fonctions vous
les exercer pour que
la loi et la réglementation soit
appliquée
s'agit de dire aux partis si elles ont
un litige
comment elle ce litige doit se terminer
pour que leurs actions soient en
conformité avec les dispositions légales
et règlementaires et avec les règles de
la concurrence
je vais vous dire non monsieur le
sénateur m'excuser parce que évidemment
évidemment que je suis amené à rappeler
les termes de la loi ou la
réglementation quand il le faut mais
l'objectif d'une médiation c'est de
trouver un accord c'est de sortir d'un
litige avec un accord
oui mais voilà même temps vous avez pas
évidemment il vaut mieux que cet accord
ne soit ne n'est pas pour objectif de
détourner la halle de contourner la loi
bien entendu mais l'objectif c'est
vraiment de sortir avec un accord donc
encore une fois il arrive bien sûr que
je sois amené à rappeler la
réglementation ou la loi
parce que parce que par exemple les
parties vont trop loin
aj des arguments qui n'ont pas lieu
d'être c'est plutôt pour calmer le débat
a ramené à ramener les choses à mener le
litige à sa juste dimension mais
l'objectif c'est de trouver un accord
est ce que le cnc vous saisit aussi ou
est-ce que c'est simplement les
distributeurs et les y seraient ils
seraient en tout à fait loisible au cnc
de me saisir ça ne m'est pas arrivé
oui voilà donc c'est arrivé une fois
dans l'histoire de de la médiature
sur les fonctionnements des dispositifs
scolaires
des cinémas qui participent au
dispositif scolaire
mais c'est très rare
l'objectif c'est de trouver une
conciliation
mais ce n'est pas toujours le cas et
vous avez un pouvoir d'injonction oui
est-ce que ce pouvoir est ce que cette
injonction s'impose au parti
de fait elle ça elle s'impose
et il le considère ainsi
mais si vous voulez
si la partie qui est reçoit cette
injonction ne
ne la met pas en pratique
pour pouvoir faire intervenir la
toute toute la force de
l'exécution de cette injonction il faut
passer par un tribunal faut passer par
une juridiction compétente qui frappe
l'italie mais c'est extrêmement rare
c'est c'est
ça a pu exister mais c'est une pratique
très rare quand il y à une injonction
elle est appliquée parce que parce que
parce que si les demander
à une juridiction de la rendre
applicable
en général ça sera suivie
et quel est le quelle est la voie de
recours
contre une injonction le conseil d'état
et quels sont vos les relations du du
médiateur avec le ministère
elles sont
comment dire assez
elles sont elles sont régulières mais
mais assez espacées
il est le ministère en tout cas pendant
mon mandat
ne m'a jamais saisie de
sujets particuliers
concernant concernant
mes fonctions donc ya pas il n'y a pas
du tout de
d'intervention
qui qui nous conduirait à travailler
plus dans un domaine que dans un autre
où des choses de gens là donc il n'y a
pas d'intervention je pense que le
ministère est satisfait
d'avoir cet outil qui facilite les
choses sur un point qui est assez
sensible si vous voulez bon il faut bien
avoir conscience que la diffusion des
oeuvres en salle c'est un segment
de l'économie du cinéma qui est
assez peu médiatique assez bon voilà on
s'intéresse beaucoup à des tas de sujets
qui sont en amont de tout ça un cookie
ou qui sont qui en forment l'ossature le
cadre général
mais il est rare que que qu'il y ait
vraiment des sujets fortement politique
ou fortement médiatique sauf au niveau
local sur sur la diffusion des films en
salles
bon c'est arrivé c'est arrivé et il me
vire
les litiges qui ait pu y avoir sur les
champs-elysées ont quand même défrayé la
chronique bon mais ça n'est pas
nécessairement
un sujet par contre je pense que le
ministère a tout à fait conscience que
c'est un sujet qui est très important
extrêmement importante dans le quotidien
du cinéma parce que c'est un goulot
d'étranglement
très très net
donc
donc il faut que ça fonctionne et les
éléments de régulation qui permettent de
donner de mettre du lien de faciliter
les choses sont extrêmement précieux
vous avez dit que vous pouviez
intervenir par exemple
pondu concurrence sur les questions de
festival mais en quoi
en quoi avez-vous intervenir est-ce
qu'il ya la création de festivals qui
peut poser problème au point de vue de
la concurrence ont connu la régulation
du
alors
ça nous était arrivé d'être saisie pour
des poudres encore une fois ces jours
des sujets bien précis
quand un
un festival
et créer ou fonctionne et décide d'une
programmation
il nous est arrivé d'avoir des litiges
entre le distributeur d'un film qui va
être présenté à ce festival là et
l'exploitant de la ville où se tient le
festival
parce que par exemple dans le cas dans
le cas en question
l'exploitant avait un accord avec le
distributeur pour sortir son film en
sortie nationale qui se trouvait être
évidemment en même temps que le festival
dont mai mais en fait à ce moment là le
fils n'était pas encore prévu comme
devant sortir au festival donc pour
l'exploitant il estimé que
n'ayant pas été prévenus qu'ils auraient
ce type de concurrence avec avec des
sorties au festival ils étaient lésés
voilà bon c'est ce genre de c'est ce
genre de sujet
il ya une sorte de captation de
clientèle
voilà alors en même temps
encore une fois bon on a été saisie une
fois ou peut-être deux sur un sujet
différent mais
mais des festivals en france il n'en
existe deux un très grand nombre donc ça
fonctionne bien l'organisation des
festivals en général ne génère pas de
litige il arrive c'est pour vous dire
que la tension des exploitants devient
grande puisque
dans un cas comme ça peut-être que dans
le passé ne nous aurait pas saisie
d'accord vous avez dit aussi que sur les
décisions de commissions départementales
vous exercez vous faisiez des recours
dans 10 % des cas
oui c'est ce qu'il semble ressortir de
nos statistiques c'est considérable
elles sont c'est pas du tout un objectif
bien voilà pour moi c'est juste le
résultat d'un examen au cas par cas
commissions départementales sont trop
permissive elle donne son autorisation
moi je ne dirais pas ça je dis
simplement que au cas par cas
j'ai des cas de figure absolument de
toute nature
je sais pas ça va ça va du cas où la
commission départementale a donné a
donné son accord
pour
un
signe un établissement qui se trouve au
ras d'une dune d'une zone à danger
risque d'exposition aux inondations fort
mais aura vraiment c'est à dire que
l'eau le coin du bâtiment et aura de la
zone rouge il faut considérer que ça
c'est de votre compétence oui c'est de
la compétence malheureusement parce que
c'est pas vraiment mon mont mais oui je
dois regarder l'ensemble des critères
qui permettent à enfin sur lesquels
doivent être jugés les projets dont
l'environnement et
enfin ça c'est tout à fait quand même
c'est tout à fait exceptionnel ça m'est
arrivé ça veut dire que vous considérez
on est quand même dans on a la
démonstration
de la
du délitement de notre pauvre république
parce que considéré que le médiateur du
cinéma a compétence pour exercer un
recours contre une décision de la
commission départementale sur des
problèmes de risques d'inondations alors
qu'il ya quand même des procédures
permis de construire je trouve que c'est
assez oui je vous ai cité cet exemple là
parce qu'il est
c'est le seul que j'ai jamais vu bon
mais c'est simplement parce que les
textes sont donne un pouvoir de recours
qui est qui se rapporte à l'ensemble des
critères ce qui est parfaitement normal
il n'ya pas délimité sur quels critères
pouvait porter le pour y porter leur
cause mais dans l'aube et les recours
que je suis amené à former sont
pratiquement tous liés au fait qu' on
commence à être sur un ont commencé à
être sur un marché qui est
tellement équipe et
que l'implantation d'un nouveau
multiplexe
peut devenir un problème peut devenir un
problème c'était dans le sens que
non seulement il n'apportera rien la
diversité des oeuvres qui seront
projetés mais il va tout simplement
aboutir à un éclatement de de dison de
des entrées qui va être préjudiciable
aux oeuvres et qui va rien apporter aux
habitants voilà alors dans des cas de
figure de ce genre là où dans des cas de
figure où on voit bien que le multiplex
qui se créent va déstabiliser la zone
est donc en particulier conduire à des
difficultés économiques importantes pour
des opérateurs de type salah art essai
de centre ville
bon là
là
ce sont des recours à ces nuances et que
je suis amené à faire c'est pas c'est
pas du tout ou rien jeu
j'explique à la commission dans le
détail mais mes raisons mais il m'arrive
très souvent de proposer que l'opérateur
qui est demandeur
limite sa programmation c'était
utilisent cet outil qui est à la
disposition des commissions
départementales comme nationale pour
comédiens
affichez qu'il va se contenir en une
ligne éditoriale qui permettra
le maintien de la diversité des formes
d'exploitation or le législateur a
rajouté très expressément cet objectif
dans l'ensemble de cette de cette
politique publique la diversité des
formes d'exploitation
c'est important et c'est je pense que
c'est
d'ailleurs les parties prenantes le
comprennent très bien qu'il s'agisse des
des élus locaux ou même des demandeurs
qui qui maintenant arrive avec des
propositions le gros problème c'est que
le diable se niche dans les détails et
que les propositions qui sont et qui
sont faites sont souvent très très
insuffisante
jeu j'en donne gens donnent des exemples
par exemple dans leur rapport dans le
rapport d'activité de l'an dernier si
vous voulez quand un opérateur se
présente auprès d'une municipalité et
s'engage par exemple à ne pas propre
programme et les films soutenus par la
fca et
en disant bon bah je laisse ce type de
film à mes concurrents art et essai de
centre ville par exemple faut bien faut
bien avoir conscience que ça représente
25 films par an qui sont des petits
films et que c'est absolument pas le
coeur du débat le coeur du débat
économique c'est des films art et essai
porter
qui fait qu'ils auquel les salles art et
essai doivent absolument avoir accès
pour pouvoir avoir un modèle économique
qui tienne la route voilà donc c'est
délicat il faut quand même que les
engagements de programmation porte sur
quelque chose qui est vraiment du sens
sinon c'est de la poudre aux yeux et
voilà alors les commissions
départementales quand même jusque là
était
été assez peu composé de gens compétents
en matière de cinéma alors maintenant
elles ont été elles sont elles sont
réformer et donc donc je pense que ça
devrait se passer mieux la commission
nationale également
donc
ça me parait ça me paraît important
parce que maintenant on rentre dans des
situations qui nécessitent un examen à
ses fins
tout simplement parce que le territoire
est extrêmement bien déjà
équipés alors il ya des zones où ça ne
pose aucun problème au contraire c'est
très très bienvenu qui a un multiplex
qui s'installe donc dans une très très
large majorité de kg est strictement
rien à dire
vous me demandiez est-ce que c'est des
décisions laxiste qui sont prises en
commission départementale jeunes cool je
ne crois pas du tout
je ne crois pas du tout mais je pense
que le dialogue a besoin d'être nourris
entre la profession
peut-être le cnc le médiateur du cinéma
et les élus parce que y'a vraiment des
points de vue différents et que c'est
c'est d'ailleurs très enrichissant
d'avoir d'avoir ces discussions
pour pouvoir rentrer dans le détail de
ce qui pose problème dans des projets de
ce type de ce qui peut poser des
problèmes dans ce projet là faut bien
voir que c'est grâce à la dynamique
encore une fois de la constructions de
multiplexes qu'on a équipé le pays aussi
bien et que et que finalement aussi les
établissements
préexistant à se se sont vus contraints
d'investir ce qui fait qu'on a un très
beau parc même en qualité donc c'est
quand même très encourageant
vous avez des des relations étroites
avec l'autorité de la concurrence
on a des relations
mais
il arrive que l'
autorité de la concurrence s'intéresse à
ces sujets où nous questionnent sur
comment dire le
le suivi d'affaires l'hôtel dont elle a
eu à traiter
mais
alors al'inverse si vous voulez
si j'avais connaissance de fête mettant
mettant
gravement en cause tel ou tel tel ou tel
parti en matière de concurrence
il faudrait que je saisisse l'autorité
de la concurrence ça ne m'est pas arrivé
non on a eu on a eu une circonstance où
on a demandé en quelque sorte ah ah
alors non pas à l'autorité de la
concurrence mais la dgccrf de
s'appelle maintenant
de de nous aider sur un sujet parce
qu'ils concernaient tout un territoire
c'était la réunion et que c'était un bon
il y avait une complexité si vous voulez
de
d'interactions entre les opérateurs qui
faisait qu'on avait besoin d'une étude
un peu plus détaillé que ce qu'on aurait
pu faire avec nos propres moyens ou avec
ceux d'ailleurs du cnc donc parce que à
la réunion on a on a deux opérateurs
principaux comme exploitant qui sont
aussi sous distributeurs
donc les relations sont assez complexes
très conflictuelle
voilà donc on a eu besoin de saisir la
dgccrf qui effectivement nous a fait
nous a fait un travail à ce moment-là
l'étude
serait il envisageable que la régulation
soit directement effectués par
l'autorité de la concurrence a
serait-il envisageable
assez des sujets
chers quand ils ont des sujets dans
notre domaine il nous consultent parce
qu'ils n'ont pas du tout la
pratique la compétence
donc voilà ce que je peux vous répondre
évidemment il pourrait peut-être n'ont
pas cet argument là peut être utilisé
dans une dans une quantité de domaines
parce que malgré toutes leurs qualités
et ils savent les développer les exposer
il n'en reste pas moins qu'ils ont pas
des compétences spécialisées dans tous
les domaines alors je veux donner un
autre argument plus de fond peut-être
c'est que
le parlement a voté
il n'y a pas si longtemps
une loi qui
sort
la partie par exemple donc justement
cdac du sénat c'est en matière
cinématographique du code du commerce
pour la rattacher aux codes du cinéma
donc si vous voulez la logique car on
sent bien que que la logique c'est de
considérer que c'est ensemble là
son plus proche d'une politique de
régulation
de du domaine du cinéma que d'une
politique de la concurrence au sens pur
et dur
dur à porter
je m'interroge quand même de savoir si
vous seriez pas mieux pour vous d'être
rattachées justement à l'autorité de la
concurrence
en termes de même en termes de moyens au
lieu de dépendre du cnc pourquoi
médiateur du cinéma serait pas quelqu'un
de spécialisé dans le cadre de
l'autorité indépendante que ferait
l'autorité de la concurrence franchement
c'est tous ces poids et vous n'êtes pas
la seule d'ailleurs il ya là d'autres
devraient avoir la même il me semble que
ça serait plus logique et plus plus
simple quelque part en terme de
véritable indépendance de faire partie
d'une grande
hays qui serait l'autorité de la
concurrence
kaka sera l'inconvénient selon vous
cette formule
qui dureront vision personnelle dans la
commission denquête mais à mon avis
c'est difficile je pense de rattacher
des activités de médiation à une
autorité de la concurrence parce que la
médiation repose sur la confiance
l'activité de médiation c'est c'est à ce
moment là je suis pas du tout un juge
jeu on
peut me dire tous y compris des horreurs
et moi il faut que je réagisse pour
d'une part ben
rétablir ce qui doit l'être mais aussi
trouver une issue
c'est un la médiation c'est quand même
vraiment mettre à plat quelque chose
entre les parties c'est très
jédir c'est très intime
j'ai fait un petit peu de médiation
familiale
dans une autre vie où j'étais avocat
voilà mes et donc c'est plus que
peut-être que la bannière autorités de
la concurrence de ce point de vue là et
n'est pas une image positive surtout il
faut voir qu'on est dans le milieu du
cinéma donc on a on a affaire bien sûr à
des gens qui ont une activité économique
à faire tourner donc ils ont cet aspect
là mais c'est le milieu c'est le milieu
du cinéma donc ils sont aussi
extrêmement attachés à leur métier dans
le sens valeurs culturelles
le sens qu'il ya beaucoup d'arguments
qu'on peut utiliser en médiation qui
sont pas du tout du domaine de la
concurrence qui sont vraiment du domaine
de
comment valoriser au mieux un film pour
qu'il rencontre au mieux son public les
tous les acteurs de la filière sont très
sensibles aussi à quelqu'un de bien
spécialisés reconnus comme tels dans cet
avis je vois pas ce que ça changerait
les high en une volonté de d'émettre des
avis elles elles ont pour objet t elle
émet des avis c'est ce que fait un
médiateur il émet un avis il essaie de
concilier les parties je t'assure que la
plupart des habits qu'on a vu c'est leur
fonction première assez d'émettre des
avis c'est pas loin de la médiation ici
on appelle médiation là on l'appelle
autrement
en général je n'aimais pas d'avis dans
ce cadre là pas du tout mais c'est bien
quand même si on dire je fais je suis
d'accord quand même pardon c'est bien
sûr votre avis que les gens se mettent
d'accord
moi je dois en réunion
un site et susciter
explorer toutes les pistes possibles
d'accord
donc moi je les aide en leur disant bon
alors si ça ça va pas est ce qu'on peut
regarder ça est-ce qu'on peut travailler
sur tel aspect est ce que je les aide à
je recherchais des terrains d'accord
mais
alors je bien sûr que je leur donne
aussi mon avis mais ils peuvent se
mettre d'accord sur quelque chose qui
n'était pas a priori mon avis
et je ne publie pas ça c'est l'accord
reste un accord entre eux il m'arrive de
publier des choses je vous dis quand je
pense que vraiment la situation qui met
exposé sur laquelle on a eu l'occasion
de réfléchir en réunion à quelque chose
de plus large que le cas de figure qui
m'est présenté et que à cette occasion
là ça vaudrait la peine de dire de dire
quelque chose donc à ce moment je publie
quelque chose d'une recommandation
j'appelle ça mais qui est dissocié si
vous voulez du cas précis qui a été
traité ce et c'est quel est l'apport à
la réflexion générale que ce cas précis
peut apporter
voilà mais
alors il ya un autre aspect pratique
c'est que le vous disiez bond sera leur
attachement différent il ya quand même
un intérêt tout à fait majeur à être
rattachés au cnc ou être très proche du
cncc que nous avons absolument besoin
des bases de données du cnc et ça je
pense que si on veut un médiateur
économe il faut pas doublonner ce genre
de choses donc
c'est le cnc qui gère c'est quand même
des bases de données absolument
gigantesque 1 puisque celle et remontée
des bordereaux des exploitants de la
france entière
évidemment on s'amuse absolument pas à
doublonner genre de choses donc nous
nous sommes utilisateurs des bases de
données du cnc qui nous sont infiniment
précieuse
c'est
toutes ces entreprises
distributeurs
exploitants
je vous demande jamais d'intervenir par
rapport aux chaînes de télévision
c'est pas de ma compétence et
non non non non non on a vraiment non
j'ai pas le souvenir je ne sais pas
non on n'a pas eu de cas de figure de
ceux de ce type là
parce que
enfin studiocanal est un distributeur
donc mais là c'est pas une chaîne de
télévision
ça a des conséquences sur la
fréquentation des salles
les conséquences sur la fréquentation
des salles en fait le
la période d'exclusivité en salles aux
yeux de l'ensemble de la profession
c'est une période
extrêmement importante
mais même la toute première période la
sortie nationale est la première semaine
c'est une période complètement crucial
qui calibre le succès du film voilà
alors évidemment avoir eu des
négociations en amont avec avec des
chaînes de télévision ça change
complètement la donne économique mais si
vous voulez en termes de succès du film
ce qui est déterminant c'est ce qui se
passe à sa sortie nationale et dans
l'est dans la première semaine
et ça là dessus les chaînes de
télévision n'ont aucun
en dehors peut-être de 2 des émissions d
émission de critique de cinéma ça c'est
autre chose
une autre question mais chaque fois jean
louis touraine
oui
moi je ne connaissais rien aux autorités
administratives indépendantes ans que je
me félicite de faire partie de cette
commission j'apprends et je m'enrichis
et plus j'entend et plus je me rends
compte que ces autorités administratives
dont on parle très peu de comptes faits
dans la presse parce qu'elle disparaisse
derrière le pouvoir politique
ont une importance très grande part les
décisions qu'elles prennent part les
avis qu'elle donne qui faute d'avoir
d'autres possibilités de recueillir des
renseignements sont forcément en grande
partie suivi ces autorités
administratives je me rends compte mais
je peux me tromper mais jusqu'à présent
voilà ce que j'en tire dessine
grandement tout de même le paysage
administratif politique culturelle de
notre pays
et je vais prendre pour exemple ce que
vous m ce qui m'inquiète
c'est le fait que
l on
elles ont une espèce de parenté en
matière de formation d'expérience
et que par conséquent il ya une certaine
philosophie certains schémas de pensée
qui les anime et qui les amène à prendre
des décisions qui peuvent être tout
confort mais empêche peut-être que nous
évoluons davantage vers des progrès vers
vers de l'inventivité la créativité
c'est pas un procès c'est juste la
réflexion que je me fais aujourd'hui je
vous ai entendu évoquer les multiplexes
et le raisonnement que qui se tient
d'ailleurs un cas sa parfaite logique
raisonnement que vous avez
exprimé c'est les multiplexes nous
sommes favorables nous avons
en france une diversité de multiplexe et
une grande qualité de ceux-ci cependant
il nous arrive d'avoir des avis
défavorable parce que ça peut mettre en
péril un certain nombre de salles d'art
et essai
peut-être d'autres salons en clair il y
a une vision des choses qui est une
vision un peu sur le plan concurrentiel
c'est à dire économique est ce qu'on va
pas mettre en péril un certain nombre ou
culturelle puisque c'est aussi en même
temps il faut se rendre compte que les
multiplexes dans la plupart des cas à
son talent sont implantés à la
périphérie des villes
que les cinémas par ailleurs les autres
cinémas sont implantées au centre vide
et pour l'expérience que j'en ai mais ça
n'a pas valeur scientifique parce que
j'ai pas d'étude là dessus mais pour
l'expérience que j'en ai je me suis
aperçu que le monde rural tir est ample
bénéfice de l'implantation des
multiplexes à la périphérie que le
nombre de spectateurs et je trouve que
le monde rural a bien le droit aussi
d'avoir accès aux grandes oeuvres
cinématographiques et une diversité de
propositions donc des multiplexes il ya
certes un certain nombre de salles qui
existant en milieu rural mais qui
propose un film film ou deux films au
maximum ce qui ne nous amène pas un
appétit supplémentaire pour une
population et lorsque vous dites il faut
faire très attention à ça je me dis que
vous ne voyez sans doute mais c'est de
mon point de vue encore une fois il est
certainement critiquable noyer sans
doute que l'un des versants en disant il
faut protéger ceux qui existent pourquoi
tout simplement ne pas mettre en oeuvre
que lorsqu'on accorde des autorisations
pour les multiplexes
l'obligation qui leur serait fait de
faire aussi du cinéma d'art et essai
sachant que l'ambition tout de même la
plus importante que nous puissions avoir
en tant qu'élu c'est bien d'amener de
plus en plus de populations et notamment
du milieu rural a fréquenté les cinémas
parce que c'est c'est une école
merveilleuse c'est la moyens de
développer son appréhension culturel qui
est incomparable alors pourquoi les ne
pas leur donner toutes les facilités
pour le faire
alors
vous évoquiez l'uniformité des dés
comment dire delà de la pensée ou des
méthodes des autorités indépendantes
là je dois dire que
je ne vous suis pas du tout parce que
elles ont très peu de relation les unes
avec les autres à ma connaissance enfin
moi j'ai j'ai même pas de relations avec
les autres médiateurs qui existent sur
la place j'ai tenté de le faire mais bon
chacun ayant beaucoup d'activités
voilà
donc non je suis pas convaincu que qu'il
y ait une méthode autorité indépendante
ou une façon de voir les choses
pas du tout je pense que vous avez en
face de vous vraiment une mosaïque mais
qui est aussi une mosaïque dans le
concret c'est à dire c'est pas c'est pas
des gens qui travaillent ensemble ou qui
ensuite vous avez parlé de deux
dons de la partie équipements
cinématographique du pays
alors je voulais je voulais vous dire
que moi je n'ai aucun a priori
sur les multiplex je voulais dit
d'ailleurs dans mon expérience
personnelle j'ai vécu en zone rurale
comme en zone urbaine et j'ai fréquenté
toutes sortes de cinéma et en zone
rurale vous avez des sales vous avez
même en zone de montagne des
signaux des réseaux itinérant des cinéma
itinérant
et je pense que justement l'objectif de
la loi qui a été votée en 2014 donc et
qui a ajouté
maintenant les objectifs de la politique
publique du cinéma le maintien et la
protection du pluralisme dans le secteur
de l'exploitation cinématographique
l'idée c'est bien de maintenir une
pluralité
pas seulement dans les oeuvres puisque
ça s'est inscrit c'est un objectif qui
est inscrit depuis très longtemps mais
aussi dans les formes d'exploitation
pourquoi parce que des formes
d'exploitation correspondent à des à des
types de programmation éventuellement
fort différent voilà donc
vous avez des multiplexes
qui ne font pas d'art et essai ou très
peu et je trouve qu'il est tout à fait
important que ça existe parce qu'il ya
un public pour ça vous avez des
multiplexes dont la ligne au niveau
national c'est de s'impliquer de plus en
plus dans l'art et essai
et j'ai ensuite tout dépend des endroits
où ils sont impliqués implanté sur le
territoire
j'ai un multiplex qui est implantée dans
une zone où il a un quasi monopole
je trouve normal
qu'il a sur la diversité des oeuvres
cette fois ci c'est à dire que
qu'effectivement ils prennent des
engagements de projeter des
films art et essai de projeter des films
de cinématographie peut diffuser qu'ils
diffusent des films issus de
distributeurs de petits distributeurs
oui je trouve tout à fait normal que
dans une zone où il est où il est en
quasi monopole ils aient des obligations
je dirais même très nettement renforcée
par rapport à ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui
par contre dans une zone où cette
diversité là est déjà assurée par les
formes d'exploitation qui existe
je pense que non il faut pas lui lui
imposer de faire particulièrement de la
diversité en matière d'art et essai ou
de quoi que ce soit d'autre puisqu'il a
d'autres il ya d'autres exploitants de
cinéma qui assure déjà cette fonction
sur le terrain et qu'ils le feront mieux
que lui ce qu'il faut bien voir qu'un
multiplexe et pas forcément
et pas forcément le mieux à même de
faire une animation autour de petits
films si vous voulez le public va
volontiers voir des films dont il a
entendu parler mais il ya de très
nombreux films dont vous n'entendez pas
parler ou très peu à moins d'être d'être
vraiment très accroché et donc le
travail des salles en particulier des
salles art et essai